you just popped it Kanye West get right
for the summer work that chain and
ladies exactly you might better pull you
a rapper hey everyone I'm Ethan thanks a
lot to the hustle con folks for having
me before we get to what I'm supposed to
talk about it's five ish you guys have
been sitting all day we're gonna stretch
everyone get up I'm gonna do it with you
get up get up get up get up get up
everyone get up all right you're gonna
put your hands up you're gonna grab your
left wrist with your right hand and
you're gonna lean over to your right
side hold it for five yeah the opposite
side of me five four three two one
switch hands we're gonna go the other
side five four feel it on your right
side three two one let go grab your
hands behind your back interlock your
fingers and lift as high as you can
you're gonna open up your chest and
ideally hit the person behind you four
five four three two one that's it thank
you sit down
all right so let me grab my clicker so
for those of you who don't know Optive
is an on-demand audio fitness product
our members pay $99 a year for unlimited
access to a large on-demand content
library we have twenty two categories of
classes over 2,500 classes and we
released 40 new classes a week we try to
remove barriers from fitness so we don't
think that it should be about you know
how much money you can afford to spend
or how close you live to a studio or
some fancy new equipment so we focus
exclusively on audio content our
trainers motivate you they guide you
through workouts and we have everything
from treadmill to strength training to
rowing to boxing and we've grown quite
well we launched the business three
years ago we have raised a little over
fifty million dollars we announced our
Series C just two days ago which was a
twenty two million dollar round we had
thank you
we had invest this time this time we
raise money from some strategic so we
had Amazon Disney and Warner Music
invest in the company which is an
exciting vote of confidence from some
key players in the space so we launched
the business three years ago and we grew
beautifully we did five thousand dollars
of revenue in November of 2015 and 1.7
million in July of 2017 so that's a 24%
compounded monthly growth rate over that
period which is cool the problem with
that level of growth is that growth is
very expensive and the problem with
expensive growth is that you burn an
obscene amount of money so we realized
that we were burning a little over two
million dollars a month and in July we
burned July of 17 we burned 2.4 million
dollars and you know burn is an
interesting thing
that's been talked about a lot because
it's very relevant and important there's
sort of the tactical challenges with
burn right which is you're actually
running out of money you have to pay
people you have to pay for things etc
but if you ignore the tactical problems
with burn the real problem is that
you're losing control of your company
you're losing control of the thing that
you want to build because if you're
constantly burning money you're
constantly raising money and if you're
constantly raising money you're at the
whim of the investor community you don't
get to have this say that you want to
have on the product that you're building
a product is a perspective those of you
who are founders are building a product
because you have a perspective on the
way that the world should be and if
you're a high burn company you will
inevitably lose control of that
perspective so we asked ourselves how do
we stop the burn and there's typically
three options associated with reducing
burn the first one is layoffs I wasn't
going to do that I I love my team there
they're fundamental and crucial to
everything that we do there's there's
simply no way I was going to layoff my
team to save the cash burn it's it's not
something that would be fair to them
fear out of the business or fair to the
members the other option that some
people suggested was to slow down our
acquisition spend you know we're a young
company many of you are founders you
have young companies I think that the
number one piece of leverage the highest
point of leverage that any of us have
against whoever the large behemoth is in
the space that we're trying to disrupt
is speed
that's the highest point of leverage
that I need us have and if we slow down
our acquisition spend that means we slow
down our growth that means we lose speed
and if you lose speed you're giving up
everything so I wasn't going to do that
either we asked ourselves is there some
kind of third magical solution that
we're not thinking of or that you know
people haven't advised us about or that
we don't read about and we realized
fortunately that there was and that was
to fix the working capital position of
the business
so let's talk about working capital for
those of you who don't know what it is
working capital is basically looking at
the cash inflows of the business and the
cash outflows of the business and what
you want to do is set yourself up such
that you have a positive cash balance
between the money that's coming in and
the money that's going out and a lot of
people don't talk about it you know
especially in the startup community it's
not something that's a topic of
conversation we sort of see an invoice
that's due and we pay it out or we book
some revenue and we don't really care if
it comes in 5 10 15 30 60 days that's
absolutely the wrong way to think about
your business the cash position of your
business the inflows and outflows will
determine the success of the product
you're trying to build it literally is
the amount of control you have in your
product and I know that sounds I don't
know dramatic or bullshitty or whatever
but I promise you the more control you
have over your cash position the more
control you'll have on your product and
ultimately that's what you're there for
that's what you want to build so we're a
subscription business we generate
lifetime value of a member and so we
said how do we improve our working
capital and it was either to increasing
the lifetime value of the member and
receiving them and/or receiving the
money earlier so to increase the
lifetime value of the member we sell our
products online but we also sell it
through the iOS and Android App Store
and as anyone who does this knows it
sucks because you have to pay 30% to
Android and Apple to do that so when I
say see LTV up there I'm talking about
the contribution lifetime value which is
net of merchant fees and net of any cost
of goods sold
it's your gross margin basically so we
could improve our merchant fees which
would mean that we would sell it on web
instead of through Apple or Android so
on web we pay 2.7 percent on alpha or
Android we pay 30 percent so that's a 27
point 3 percent savings like that number
two is we could increase our conversion
so if we increase the frequency in the
rate of conversion we're increasing risk
LTV and last was to actually improve the
retention of our members from year one
to year two year to year three etc which
increases the lifetime value so that was
on the CLT
side then we said how do we receive the
money earlier there was a couple of
options there number one was to explore
alternative pricing options so we're a
subscription business we chart well
before this we charge $10 a month for
unlimited access to all of our content
and that $10 a month price point we
didn't really test into it we sort of
you know it felt right but we realized
that maybe we should be testing into it
a little bit more so we explored
alternative pricing options including an
annual plan and we now have an annual
plan that's $100 a year you pay that
upfront and we change the price of our
monthly to $15 a month so well we
realize that it's more valuable for us
to receive $100 upfront than $15 over 12
or $180 over 12 months broken down $15
increments because of net present value
because of cash flows because of working
capital so depending on how your
business's work depending on your
pricing schemes there may be a
meaningful discount which is worth it to
get the money upfront that was the case
for us the other option for us was
financing structures so for those of you
who receive money through iOS and
Android
you typically receive it 45 or 60 days
later so we tried to see can we finance
those receivables to receive the cash
sooner so what we realize is this the
summary of all this is that we needed to
sell annual subscriptions on the web so
how do we do that the first thing that
we did is we built out a robust
engineering team dedicated to the web
product the second thing we did is we
said why don't we actually make the web
product
our primary focus from a traffic
perspective so any ads any marketing any
partnerships that we did instead of
sending people to the app store let's
send them to the web where again we pay
a significantly lower merchant fee the
third thing we did is we said why don't
we make the web our website a place that
people actually want to come for great
experiences for great content as opposed
to just making it you know a page where
we're just trying to convert people as
much as possible why don't we actually
make it a really exciting place to be
despite that we also said let's continue
testing the share out of it to make it a
really great sales page so we did a lot
of a/b testing
a lot of iterations on pricing
fortunately the result of all of this
work is that we went from burning 2.4
million dollars in a single month to
actually be in cashflow positive seven
months later and this to be quick
okay I just realized that Jeff is
totally wrong we're not throwing out
money that's not the message I'm trying
to show here we're supposed to reverse
it's supposed to come in where we were
started receiving money it was positive
by the end of that he looked cool doing
it okay you can do this if you focus on
the working capital situation in the
business and it took a lot of work from
our team to do it but it completely
changed the control that we had on the
business it can we control it now we
control our cash position which means we
control the product and the perspective
that we have I hope this is helpful for
you guys for those of you who are
founders or entrepreneurs I know the
cash tough cash balance management is
really challenging so I hope this is
helpful feel free to find me on LinkedIn
or my Twitter handle which is right
there thank you
[Applause]
[Music]